[Music]
came to Vilnius hoping for a firm
invitation to join the NATO alliance and
a timeline for accession he goes away
with neither an outcome that he said on
Tuesday would be absurd that earned him
a rare rebuke from the UK defense
minister who said zielinski ought to
show more gratitude which he later did
we have positive very positive news
about new defense support packages from
our partners and on the sidelines of the
summit we've already started these
meetings we have the agreements and I
thank each of the leaders who offered us
these packages
he leaves with a package of measures
that NATO says will draw Ukraine closer
with a pathway to membership sometime
after the war is over and G7 countries
offering long-term security guarantees
that will ensure Ukraine's defense
across land sea and air
NATO's Secretary General Jen stoltenberg
reaffirmed that Ukraine's future lies
within the alliance
today we meet as equals
I look forward to the day we meet as
allies the next best thing to Nato
membership for Ukraine comes in the form
of those G7 guarantees to be negotiated
that will support not just Ukraine's
long-term security but also its economy
reconstruction and efforts towards good
governance
President Biden called it a powerful
statement that the Allies will support
Ukraine for as long as it takes before a
speech setting out his vision of a
strong confident America flanked by
strong confident allies
Craven lost for land and power unleashes
brutal war on Ukraine he was betting
NATO would break apart
he was betting NADA would break
he thought our Unity would shatter at
the first testing he thought Democratic
leaders would be weak
but he thought wrong
Biden moves on to meet Nordic leaders in
Helsinki the end of a European tour
showcasing America's ambition for
leadership in the world that may leave
some wondering how much of that
leadership will remain beyond the next
U.S election Jonah Hall Al Jazeera
Vilnius
well the Kremlin has been watching those
developments closely here's it spokesman
Dimitri peskov
IC
we considered as a mistake and
potentially very dangerous because
providing any security guarantees to
Ukraine effectively ignores the
international principle of indivisible
security that said providing security
guarantees to Ukraine encroaches the
Russian Federation security this is
impossible this is fraud with very short
medium and long-term negative
consequences